let's talk about some wins we got the
story from newsweek by journalist andy
no oh
prosecutors make first move to break up
anti facile as 11 activists charged with
charged with violence
now this is not an opinion piece this is
a factual news report by uh by andy no
for newsweek and the reason i'm
emphasizing a factual news report by
journalist andy noe is because
anti-fun these extremists
have tried their hardest to smear and
besmirch his name simply for reporting
on what they do
this is it
newsweek is not some far-right
publication or some conspiracy blog
music's actually fairly left-leaning
and here we have a factual news piece
you see prosecutors are actually going
after antifa they say andy writes this
week the san diego county district
attorney's office charged 11 alleged
antifa members with felony conspiracy
and felony assault charges among other
crimes in a riot case
where supporters of former president
donald trump and random bystanders were
beaten in the pacific beach uh in
pacific beach california in january
eight suspects were arraigned this week
they have all pleaded not guilty
there's there's videos of what happened
there there are reports that there were
miners who were simply walking down the
street and auntie decided to attack and
pepper spray them there was a guy who
was apparently long boarding with his
dog and they pepper spray this guy
for no reason because they assume if
you're there you must be a trump
supporter oh hey i'm i'm curious here
you know
i think we should be happy that finally
we're seeing law enforcement go after
antifa
right
this is finally how long has it taken
but my concern is is it too little too
late and is it just kind of a show some
appeasement you know what i mean are
they actually going to get serious
across the board around the country and
deal with this extremism well i want to
know exactly what happened in this
particular case before kind of exposing
an opinion on it but what brings me
to think about you know when when i hear
about this story was just a few months
ago when antifa was caught celebrating
because their opponents were being
arrested they were celebrating when the
fbi was going after trump supporters and
my first comment on them celebrating it
it's only a matter of time until the
state turns against you and starts
arresting you so i think this could be
the first of that i still wanna i still
don't know a lot of the details around
this case but did do they have any
charges against these individuals yeah
conspiracy and felony assault yep oh
okay among other crimes yeah dude do
they know uh let's see if i can come
down they come
yeah okay so we have you know samuel
ogden charged with felony conspiracy and
assault we've got jesse cannon
uh felony conspiracy felony assault so
you know basically they're all being
charged similarly and it's for trying to
cause a great bodily harm to individuals
they're fundraising to try and and try
and deal with this these people thought
they were untouchable
they felt like that the cops couldn't do
anything and you know what for several
years that was the case right
well the cops weren't doing anything for
for a long time and as we know the the
cops and the feds have a lot of uh data
they're they're running huge dragnet uh
information operations where they
literally are flying drones over a lot
of these protests they know a lot more
than they let on so i would say that you
know the federal authorities the
surveillance grids know almost
everything so to see this kind of turn
when they were previously cheered on by
many establishment institutions for
doing these actions to see them now face
the ramifications of them shows a kind
of very interesting turn i mean
there could be just not enough
right-wingers for them to go after for
the petty crimes so they're like okay we
got to do something now right now they
might be going away yeah we got to do
something to justify these overly huge
budgets that we got uh but um it's gonna
be i'm i may not i need to read more
into this i wonder if this is actually
because the midterms are coming up and
the establishment democrats know that
this is a huge problem
i do think also though the courts have
proven to be the front lines lately and
it's been pretty fascinating to watch
justice at work you had um
you know the charlottesville stuff came
up and those white supremacist groups or
whatever were fined like
so much money enough money to completely
bankrupt them out of existence which is
kind of you know but they don't look the
and you had written house that was
proper justice this wallet trial the
shots are very interesting suing private
citizens who have no money just doesn't
do anything no i mean that's not
effective right i mean it's not going to
be effective for that but it is you know
an interesting thing to see that the
courts are really on the front lines of
this if you look at the most um if the
biggest stories that we've had lately
they've all been trials it's all been
like waiting for a verdict
you know
yeah that's been that's been pretty wild
you know the supreme court oral
arguments have been heating up the whole
situation with the abortion laws
courts are the front lines they're the
it's interesting too because once things
hit the courts you know
that's really where
that's really where you're going to
start to see what's going to happen like
what the precedent is going to be what
the law is going to be next year in june
the it's widely believed that the
supreme court's going to overturn roe v
wade yeah and that was leftist activists
there was one guy from i think from
slate he was like that's it it's done
the supreme court will overturn roe v
wade and everyone started freaking out
he's like no no it's a prediction not a
statement of fact but it's probably true
and uh even like nbc was saying this now
i say this in the context of antifa
what will
how the far left will be able to rally a
lot of crazy young people around this
should it happen
but that will be bad for democrats right
it will be bad for democrats the other
thing that's bad for democrats is that
they had to base abortion rights on a
supreme court decision and they could
never actually pass it on a federal
level it's a states rights issue it's
not elucidated in the constitution when
you heard the oral arguments i guess it
was whenever it was last week and
justice thomas who is so interesting
whenever he talks it's so interesting
because he was you know he hardly ever
says anything um but he consistently was
asking what is the basis in the
constitution for abortion rights is it
liberty is it this and you know she's
the uh the woman um
yeah council just kept being like well
she said that's abortion abortion right
yeah yeah 14th amendment and it's a
liberty issue right and i don't think
that's i don't think that's good enough
and i think that it's i think it's bad
law because why is it bad law because
it's not actually a law like they don't
make a law it needs to go through
congress if they want a federal abortion
rights thing they need to make an
amendment and do it and they can't and
that's what kavanaugh said yes he said
why is this going to the court not
through legislation that's exactly right
here's what i see happening i think
antifa will definitely use that this
kind of stuff should they actually
overturn roe v wade they're gonna have a
powerful media asset to rally a bunch of
young ignorant people and people who are
not all with it if you know what i mean
into getting violent right because their
agenda is burn it to the ground and then
rebuild but the establishment democrat
their agenda is like when the moderates
over in the midterms
you've got a flailing economy you've got
a abysmal job growth you've got the
democrats trying to claim that joe
biden's we're in the biden boom
you can only lie so much when people
can't buy cereal anymore and you're
gonna add to that the extremist
crackpots going around smashing up
windows and they know it so
i wonder if this is preemptive because
they're like if we don't start arresting
these people they're going to go nuts
and it's going to be it's not going to
be a red suit a red wave a red tsunami
it is going to be a red great flood
build your ark now
i'm looking into this and these are not
federal charges it looks like this was
charges from the san diego county
district attorney san diego is has a lot
of right wingers in there so it wouldn't
surprise me if this was like a local
effort to them for them to go after
individuals that target other people and
hurt them because they worked with other
local police departments and it looks
like they have a very solid case here
as they also were able to get a whole
bunch of weapons drugs
on some of the suspects that were
arrested here i think it was eight
suspects in total there were search
warrants issued so this seems more like
a local issue rather than a federal
issue um so um i don't you know i think
that also matters that's fine yeah why
should it not be local no i'm not i'm
not saying it matters i'm just saying
that it is a local issue it's not a
federal issue yeah so about where
california leads the rest of the country
follows and i'm really optimistic that
this precedent will kind of set the
stage for some other cities to do the
same thing
do you think it will i hope so did you
know that um
i learned this from the redheaded
libertarian josie good friend of the
show that communists aren't considered
people for the for the sake of human
rights in the 1964 civil rights act so
this is really interesting actually
because i uh it's fallen out of i
suppose legal precedent but apparently
in the 1964 civil rights act it says
this provision will not be construed as
to provide you know
like rights to communists or people or
communist associated organizations or
something like that
antifa is quite literally rooted in
weimar germany's communist
anti-fascist action or whatever which
was literally a communist organization
so i wonder if there is anything there
we should be worried about or i don't
know i i certainly don't like the idea
of the government being like we've
deemed you a communist therefore because
they could call anybody a communist they
could claim anywhere right
but antifa is literally a communist
organization and you know maybe the
reason we won't actually see anything
from that provision is because we don't
care about it culturally and because
many of the people in federal law
enforcement i know this was state level
charges but many high-ranking you know
democrats are also
you know at the very least socialists
have communist leanings or are unwilling
to go after communists out of fear
yeah
i think they are afraid i think they're
afraid to go after you know i mean we
see this at the post-millennial all the
time right like these anti-foot people
are coming after us they come after andy
all of the time
um and they have this weird you know
this communist ideology and they don't
they don't really care about anything
else and they just use the fear tactics
you know they say like
don't fund this business don't put your
ads on this business don't talk to this
person because i'm telling you to so
trust me and nobody ever looks into
their background or looks into like you
know the horrible things that they've
done or what they're about it's it's
about time you know people started
waking up to what these extremists do
they lie they cheat they steal and it's
all for power and a good example as we
mentioned earlier that they're still
backing jesse smallett even after he's
been found guilty yeah but let's talk
about law fair because i am really
excited to talk about this story
from the daily dot two journalists sue
andy know over his online use of their
videos they say no reposted their videos
without permission leading to online and
physical attacks from his audience as
well i would just like to point out i do
not believe going to a court and suing
for damages and then being like people
were were threatening us online is any
grounds for any complaint against andy
no because he had nothing to do with
that that's that's
immaterial
they say two journalists have filed a
lawsuit against dandino for copyright
infringement journalists grace morgan
and melissa claudio lewis say that no
downloaded and tweeted their videos
without permission their suit seeks
damages and a permanent injunction
prohibiting no from posting their videos
without express consent now before i
show you this i would like i would like
to make one definitive statement and
prediction right now in the absolute
i welcome being wrong but
i will say it
andy no
will win on summary judgment
he will then seek legal fees
and he will win legal fees
this
lawsuit is so laughably bad
that i cannot believe they even wasted
one red cent to file it
what andy knows being accused of doing
is so beyond fair use i have to imagine
the first thing the judge is going to
say to the the plaintiffs in this case
is
are you sure about this you're going to
be billed by a lawyer for it and then he
might come after you you know andy could
file
a claim for legal fees and he will be
awarded them this is beyond frivolous
now there are lawsuits where it's like
now that's questionable at best okay so
good friend of mine cassandra fairbanks
she filed a lawsuit against some
reporter because she claimed the ok hand
sign was a white supremacy gesture and
cassandra lost because it is very
difficult to win these kinds of lawsuits
but let me show you here from the daily
dot
here are the tweets from melissa claudio
lewis she was on the ground filming she
said cops are getting guardian angels to
protect them here's one where said
moltco tried to bust out but found their
gate wasn't functional they say when and
when no andy no posted it he wrote
police observe the writing auntie from
antifa from behind a gate in downtown
portland last night and as you can see
andy no did not in fact download this
video all he did was used twitter's
internal function to repost it in a
tweet and thus you can see the woman's
name melissa claudio lewis and her video
hosted on her twitter account in andy
knows tweet in another tweet they say
he's similarly altered text altering
text is
here's the funny thing i just got it
if they're actually trying to make the
case like but but but andy is being
suited because he also altered the text
i'm like that's in defense of andy
altering text for commentary or
criticism is transformative and it's
commentary and criticism exactly here's
the best part in the uh in the next
tweet they highlight you can see that
andy know is literally reposting their
video directly through twitter's tweet
function he did not download this video
and re-upload it you can see them in
grace morgan's name in this so let me
make this very simple andy no
retweeted people on twitter taking
publicly available videos providing his
own commentary on them for a newsworthy
purpose that's correct it is it is it is
like so laughably fair use yes that he
is going to win summary judgment that
means there will be no trial the judge
is going to read it and be like
dismissed
and it's not like they turned off the
retweet function or turned off comments
or anything like that just mad that it
was andy that they just don't like andy
and it's because andy exposes them you
know he exposes them so thoroughly
um yeah and i think that he is so
correct to be fundraising for his
defense on this one so definitely so is
this a copyright complaint or harassment
complaint is
copyright he attribute he put their name
yeah
attributions are relevant yeah um i
would like to reference the notorious
case of akilah hughes v carl benjamin
carl benjamin aka sargon of akkad on
youtube
uploaded raw clips from akilah hughes's
youtube and the only thing he did he
there's nothing in the videos it's
literally her raw clips from a longer
video and he titled it liberal something
like liberal sense of self-awareness
right she sued him
sargon carl very smart he kept his mouth
shut and everyone asked him and he says
look i'm in a lawsuit i can't speak
about it right akilo went on twitter
talked her mouth off gave press comments
said here's what i'm doing i'm gonna
assume and i'm going to take everything
the judge in that case was like are you
sure you want to go forward with this
because this is very clear-cut fair use
right and akilah was like he's
infringing on my copyright he didn't
provide commentary or criticism she had
to change lawyers and carl's kept his
mouth shut carl won on summary judgment
he filed for legal fees and he won again
if andy no downloaded their videos
reposted them and then wrote lol
that would be fair use commentary and he
would win yes that's that's it yeah so
what andy noah has done here is he
didn't even download them he just used
twitter's public functions to retweet it
and all he did also was say you know and
what happens is antifa posts it and says
look at these horrible police and andy
posts it and says actually there's
another way to look at this situation
maybe take a look at it from this
perspective
you can't handle it you know and
there's more than one way to look at
anything this is a this is like a
lawsuit about messaging yeah so uh
morgan told the daily dot that they're
hoping to make it harder for andy now to
steal the journalists content and change
the narrative of their reporting
something he has built his career off of
if you post newsworthy video to twitter
where it can be seen by the public
someone can retweet you
that's something you've you you've
acquiesced to now i will say i will say
for those that are wondering
how do news wires work one of the core
the core questions of fair use is if you
are infringing upon their market now
this is important
if i post a video
on twitter there is literally no defense
i mean you can try and muster up one but
they're gonna be like look you posted
the video to twitter it's publicly
available can be shared and embedded i
don't know what you want us to do
but if i post maybe like 20 seconds and
then i say to license the full video go
to my website and someone goes to my
website takes the full version and
reposts it and says well i saw part of
it on twitter now you're actually
infringing upon my market that's
different so
pub
publishing something
makes it now available to the public it
can be transformed it can be commented
on to be fair
you it it it quite literally is
copyright infringement but there is an
exception to you know whether a judge
will allow this and it's quite quite
clear what this is actually
is i think it's called ad terrarium
that's what they were the the judge
called it in the akilah hughes case
these antifa uh journalists
are suing andy no not because they think
they'll win they're trying to drain his
resources and force them into a fight
now well and they want to force them off
twitter i mean it's so clear that they
just want to force him off twitter right
uh they don't want him to be able to do
any reporting on them and without andy i
mean andy was at the forefront of this
kind of reporting
um
an important question here libby maybe
you would know this was he crossing
state lines was he tweeting
because you know that could be another
reason to to go after him the mainstream
media is really the sorry the corporate
media really doesn't like that yeah they
really don't like when you uh leave your
home either so i don't know oh yeah
they're against that this what's amazing
is they're claiming that andy no
violated copy dmca's she's lewis says if
i had violated dmca's that many times my
account would no longer exist why andy
gets a permanent pass i can only guess
it's because he's retweeting you and
twitter allows it and when you complain
they take some of the videos down
that's it
well looks it doesn't look like a
retweet is that actually a retweet yes
format so slightly different it's
slightly different what andy did was he
took the direct link to the video and
this is a core function of twitter you
can if someone posts media you can take
their link from their twitter and put it
in a tweet and then write whatever you
want but you can see it's included her
name in it yeah this video is not being
hosted by andynow's account and it's
directly attributed right right and you
click the one's name and it shows you
their account where they've posted it
yeah and you can see what she said about
it it is literally a retweet of her
content so does this function remove the
other person's commentary yes oh okay
this this is when this this is you
retweeting the link to their media
gotcha as opposed to retweeting the
entirety of their tweet so i say retweet
because there's no real other word to
describe what this is someone posts a
video with their name on it it produces
a link on twitter that you can then
paste in your tweet which is hosted by
their account not yours so you're
basically embedding
their video in your tweet right right i
don't need retail i i don't think embed
is the right word
this video is is i i guess technically
it's the case but it's quite literally
taking their tweet their media and
putting it in yeah it might be different
tweeter has uh twitter has an option
when you uh
let's call them tweeter for now on i
think that's more appropriate when you
when you press on a video it gives you
the option to share it through multiple
platforms or tweet the video a part of
your own tweet attributing the person
who created the video
it's it's functionally retweeting yeah
you can embed if you go to
publish.twitter.com
that lets you actually embed a tweet in
another tweet but that looks well even
that's called quoting so like like luke
said you can just click the video and be
like share this video in a tweet so andy
no
isn't downloading or stealing anything
it's like here's a public video let me
comment on it well and they're
he's really careful about that you know
he wants to attribute he wants to and
that's part of it too i mean he wants to
show who the people are who are out
there making these videos and doing
these actions he doesn't want to hide
that he doesn't want to take credit for
anybody else's work
so it's a twitter feature right did he
not retweet and just type a paragraph
above their their twitter because this
format looks better
i don't know why he didn't know i know
he just literally clicked on the video
and clicked tweet video it's a better
way to do that because
so like right now i have a video up ian
right and i just pressed on it all right
and it came up and it's and i have an
option here i tweet video and then it
has the video here and i just get to
write the commentary underneath it nice
this segment it should be called
teaching ian how do you do
as it pertains to copyright law you may
disagree with this but i can literally
download this woman's video
upload it to my own twitter account and
put h
here's a video from jesse kelly the
letter from andrew pollock on twitter
it's the exact same format jessie kelly
should andrew pollock say jesse kelly
probably not no you shouldn't it's
clearly frivolous and you can see how
they've how they've they've framed this
in the article from the daily dot
they're like i'm getting harassed i'm
getting threats because andy is posting
my videos what they don't like
is that when they publish this
information they want to control the
narrative they want to frame it as
negatively as possible for the police
and for the city and andy now can take
the video provide his own commentary and
that's quite literally
look
to say it's fair use it would be like
imagine there is a 20 foot tall giant
with a big shirt that says fair use
incarnate that's what it is
there's no question like the judge is
going to be like i'm confused this is
fair use and they're going to be like
but i'm getting harassed and he's going
to be like i don't understand
what are you talking about
right also online harassment who doesn't
get online harassed doesn't every
doesn't that happen to everyone yeah the
definition has changed the definition of
harassment has definitely changed when
we would do terms of service at mines
it's like what it's not the same as like
harassment from the 80s that was when
someone was like banging on your window
and that's totally different this is
like you wake up and somebody's like
you know i hope you get killed i woke up
to this the other day actually andy was
she was like uh libby they're saying
nasty things about you now that's like
oh good what's new thanks that's
wonderful you know and this is why i
think you know this is why it's
important to support independent
journalism it's why it's important to
support journalists like andy or outlets
like the post-millennial because these
people are coming after us they're not
coming after us for any reasonable
reason we're not doing anything wrong
they just don't like that we're actually
reporting on their criminal activities
they don't want to be called out they
don't want anyone to
look at their activities from the
perspective of you know you guys are
committing crimes
you are hurting other people actually
physically hurting other people and now
you're whining that somebody's saying
something nasty about you on twitter
you're out there injuring others let me
i'll say this too there are a bunch of
uh accounts and that go into the members
only section of teamcast.com and post
those videos
and that is where they're
arguably not in fair use territory and
the reason is although they're providing
commentary or criticism on our videos
there's
this is where it gets a little bit murky
by publishing stuff that we have behind
a paywall it's arguably infringing upon
our market by giving away our content
for free however personally i'm still
fine with it right like when i see the
leftists and they're like tim paul and
his members only said x or y i'm like oh
you know look it's commentary it's
newsworthy i don't like they're giving
this away for free but it's kind of a
preview yeah so i'm not i'm not gonna be
bothered with dealing with it and i
honestly welcome the commentary and
criticism
it's it's tough because i don't want
that i mean you like you buy a book and
then you quote the book or a movie comes
out and you show a clip from it you talk
about it fair use i think that's fine
you know the thing is though if you if
there's like a movie and you take a clip
from it on youtube they'll probably just
knock you down anyway even though it is
fair use and you gotta fight for it yeah
i played a small like even a second from
the matrix uh trailer and automatically
copyright strike and like why it's not a
strike from the trailer flag uh yeah a
flag from the trailer yeah from the
trailer but aren't they isn't that out
there in order to it wasn't even it
wasn't even the trailer it was just a
few seconds as i was just like having it
in the background going through the
browser and i'm like okay wow yeah that
happened to me with uh with joe rogan
actually because i pulled up his youtube
video and was talking about the podcast
without playing it and it automatically
got flagged wow and i had to be like joe
you know it's not like can you get it
off and he was like oh sorry man but it
was automatic i've had it happen to me
too where people are like i've had um
angry leftists be like tim poole
copyright claimed my video and i'm like
no i didn't like youtube automatically
does it dude and so then i've gone in
and released it like i don't want it i
don't care
whatever
that's the thing right one of the
problems that the the the whatever the
freedom faction i guess the libertarian
little l has is that we are willing to
be like well they're allowed to use our
content to criticize us and then they
will they will sue you right so it's
it's it's look man
the sad reality is that uh cheaters win
yeah cheaters cheaters win not always
most of them get caught eventually
that's not true
you think they get caught because some
get caught but you'd be surprised how
many people are playing shady games look
everybody lies on the resume
really really i was actually encouraged
to oh i said i'm being hyperbolic okay
wait are you so serious i think people
don't lie in their resume as an actor
when i went to la they were like okay
this is the way it works in la you're
not in the union you're not sag but if
you want to be sad put sex put that your
sag on your resume and then when they
see it they'll think you're already in
the union they'll hire you and then when
they realize you're not the union
they'll just put you in the union and
that's what they did wow they hired me
for a commercial and then they just were
like well all right just give him this
union card that's wild yeah most people
line their resumes fake it until you
make it that's like a fairly common
thing i've never lied on like a other
like a non-acting resume but i was
encouraged to by my agent and it worked
it was crazy thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time